what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are like two and a half weeks
if that we're like a week and a half out
from the release of thor ragnarok
and i'm actually really excited because
i have been sitting here trying to think
of who it is it's gonna die in four
three now one of the reasons why I'm
also doing this kind of early is because
we have a lot of for stuff to cover we
have like the death of Odin Ragnarok
those of you guys who don't know and
this is actually a really cool little
tidbit when it comes to Marvel Comics
there's the ultimate universe and the
main Marvel Universe the main Marvel
Universe is what you think of when you
think of like Captain America spider-man
so on and so forth the Ultimate Universe
is cool and it had some cool moments but
for the most part the main Marvel
Universe is what people consider in the
mid-1990s Marvel launched a story where
they were trying to reinvigorate
interest in comic books due to the huge
comic busts and the fact that Marvel
almost went bankrupt and they launched a
story called heroes reborn heroes reborn
was okay I mean it was it was
interesting enough but it only lasted
for about a year after that everything
was restored and then basically a guy
named Dan Jergens took over the stories
of Thor
dan Jergens got his claim to fame
because he was the guy who wrote The
Death of Superman or at least the
biggest contributor to the death of
Superman and then the aftermath the
reign of the Superman but the idea of
was that Dan Jergens writing Thor lasted
from 1998 I think it was all the way up
until like 2005 2006 somewhere along
those lines when he basically crafted
all the events that led to Ragnarok to
the quote-unquote death of Thor and it
was super cool because we got things
like across all worlds as Thor versus
Thanos which is like this eight issue
epic it's actually pretty cool we got
like the death of Odin and different
things like that but I'm sitting here
trying to figure out who it is is gonna
die and the events of Thor Ragnarok and
as far as I'm concerned there's only
like a handful of characters who will
probably die the first question we have
to ask here is what direction is Thor
Ragnarok going to take I haven't read
anything about it I'm totally trying to
avoid spoilers if at all possible but I
feel like the Thor Ragnarok movie is
going to basically be a combination of
the Ragnarok event from the main Marvel
Comics and the origin of Thor from the
ultimate universe so let's take each of
these in stride listen let's go ahead
and run over each of these so we've
already covered the origin of ultimate
Thor you'll find that down in the
description actually I find the Thor
playlist down in the description we can
catch all kinds of cool stuff ultimate
Thor was originally
sign to be this character where you
didn't really know if he was a god or
not now this lasted until 2011 I think
2012 something like that when Marvel
lost his story called ultimate Thor and
it was basically his origin story and
what we ended up learning was that much
like the main Marvel Universe Ragnarok
event that Loki had led an invasion of
Asgard the difference is this in the
main Marvel Universe
Ragnarok unfolded where Thor basically
ran around earth and started waking up
all the Asgardians after they died in
the ultimate universe that didn't happen
instead Odin knew that Ragnarok was
coming that Asgard was going to fall and
so what he did is he basically took
everything that comprises as guard and
threw it inside the hammer of Thor
inside Mjolnir so that Asgard would live
on forever now
Thor's character basically regained his
godhood and then lost it and so on and
so forth he was reborn on earth as just
this guy the whole idea behind it was
that Loki had led an invasion of asgard
asgard had fallen and then Thor was
never able to make his way back again in
the main Marvel Universe it played out
differently in the main Marvel Universe
Ragnarok happened due to a couple things
the first was the death of Odin at the
hands of Surtur the second was that by
virtue of Odin being killed it left this
sort of power vacuum that Thor tried to
fill when he basically became the new
ruler of Asgard but he wasn't as
powerful as his father was the kicker
about all this is that there was
something called the odinforce and the
odinforce is like this II magmatic plot
device it's basically just what Marvel
uses to say that Odin's as powerful as
he is in truth the odinforce is actually
a combination of the life forces of
Odin's two brothers viele and v combined
with his own and the way this originally
happened is I believe they challenged
Serdar the first time they ever fought
and Serdar ended up killing villian v
their souls merged with Odin which
basically granted him all these new
powers and abilities and then he
interned fought Serdar and then confined
into the core of the earth something
along those lines the idea was that
during the death of Odin's storyline
Sirte was basically awakened and freed
from his prison fast forward to the
events of ragnarök loki allied himself
with Surtur and then made new hammers
and then used those hammers to basically
invade Asgard kill all the Asgardians
and then thor went on this great big
huge Vision Quest where he follow all
these paths that Odin did in order to
see what was coming later on down the
line and learned about the ones who sit
above a shadow and all this crazy stuff
that was going on the will cover once we
cover the Thor
Niraj story but the long and short of it
is that when passcard fell and four was
believed to have been dead his hammer
crashed through earth right like it flew
through hell I think it was and then
crashed through earth free dr. doom in
the process and then eventually the
hammer was picked up it was brought back
to Thor Thor returned back to the realm
of the living
and then went on this quest to begin
waking up all these ass guardians who
had been basically reborn but confined
in mortal forms not from their return
into crazy stuff Loki was reborn as a
chick and then you end up finding out
that the body was meant for SIF but Loki
stole it and so like Loki was a woman
for a while but the fact remains that
the whole idea was that it was basically
this death and rebirth of Asgard that
it's been happening for untold millennia
for countless eons and eons that Asgard
always falls by the events of Ragnarok
and Asgard has always reborn when Thor
brings it back and so again I think that
the movies gonna be a combination of
those two things I think what it's going
to do is this going to see Asgard fall
in its entirety I think all the
Asgardians are going to die just like
they did in the main Marvel Universe and
in the Ultimate Universe the difference
is I think we're gonna get the ultimate
universe version where Thor is going to
be the only survivor I think that Loki
is going to die the problem with this is
that if I'm if I remember correctly Loki
is supposed to be an infinity war so it
may be that Loki doesn't die and that's
kind of the weird thing about this is
because in the film
it looks like hella the daughter of Loki
is the one who invades Asgard in the
first place and brings Asgard crashing
down which begs the question does that
throw everything into flux because if it
was always Loki who basically brought
down Asgard and who led to the fall of
Asgard but now it's hella in the movie
does that mean Loki's gonna be just one
of the guys who tries to lay of who
tries to survive we don't have an answer
to that question I do not think that
Thor is going to die in Ragnarok
I think Thor's going to live I think
that Odin will die and I think that in
response to Odin dying that Thor will
basically inherit the odinforce which
will become the Thor force and the
reason why I say that is because right
now in the MCU if Thor would erase off
and try to fight against Thanos he would
get wrecked I mean it would it wouldn't
even be funny
Thanos without the Infinity stones we're
just wrecked Thor I mean we've seen it
countless times we saw during the events
of infinity we saw during the events of
Thor versus Thanos we saw it in like all
these different stories you know where
all this stuff happened it was crazy in
terms of how it unfolded but
if Thor inherits the odinforce then that
means that he's now more powerful than
he's ever been in the comics he
inherited the odinforce and became like
rune King Thor where he was basically
just like this godly multiversal entity
for like two pages it was crazy how
powerful he was but it would allow him
to basically have the power to rebuild
Asgard he would basically be able to
bring it all back and so I think that
what he'll do is I think we'll see Odin
dying either at the hands of Surtur or
we'll see Odin dying during the events
of Ragnarok and then we'll see Thor
absorbing the odinforce now that begs
the question what about the other as
Guardians Heimdall SIF and all the other
members of the Warriors three and you
know Balder the brave I don't think
we've seen ball over the brave in in
Thor yet for those of you guys who don't
know Thor is not the actual son of Odin
he's the son of Odin and the son of Gaia
the Spirit of Earth Balder the brave is
the son of Odin and Frigg ax she's the
only real tried and true biological son
of Odin but in the comics Balder was
hidden away because it was believed that
if Balder died it would it would be the
first stage to initiate Ragnarok and so
we know we have no idea where he is it
could be that were introduced to and
then he dies within half an hour in the
movie I have no idea regardless I think
we'll see basically Loki and Thor as the
only survivors of Asgard I think
everybody else is going to fall I think
everybody else is going to die and I
think it's gonna leave Asgard it's just
like this vacant husk this shell of what
used to be this huge Asgardian pantheon
now I think what that'll do is it'll
segue into infinity war the Thor will
basically show up with the odinforce
intact and I think the reason why Marvel
will do that is because of how impactful
it is you know when it comes to Odin and
the odinforce
he's crazy powerful we've never seen the
extent of it but in the MCU it's
basically established that Odin is one
of the most powerful beings in existence
it's just one of those things that we've
just kind of been informed of subtly and
that we kind of accept if Thor shows up
with the power of his father and then
gets rekt by Thanos with the Infinity
stones if people are just gonna be like
Jesus man this guy's powerful following
that I think that you know going after
the events of an infinity war I think
the Thor will rebuild asgaard and Asgard
will basically come back
I think it'll allow Marvel to kind of do
a reboot so to speak when it comes to
the character of Thor when it comes to
Asgard itself or whatever the case may
be because Anthony Hopkins is not gonna
play Odin for
I have no idea you know they may just be
that we never see Asgard again it may
just be that Thor just kind of takes off
and that's the end of him you know it
may be that we end up seeing things like
the introduction of beta ray bill beta
ray bill was the first character to lift
ax lift the hammer of Thor it was a huge
deal it was doing Walt Simonson's run
and it's just like this this korbinite
just shows up you know leading this ship
of his home people who were trying to
escape their planet and Thor shows up
beta ray bills like I'm a protector he
fights Thor takes his hammer and becomes
Thor it's super cool like it's one of
those really interesting stories but
again that's my theory I think that in
Thor Ragnarok we will see the death of
all the Asgardians except for Loki and
except for Thor but again I haven't
really looked at the casting of infinity
war and there's nothing to say these
characters can die and then just will be
brought back later on down the line I
mean that's entirely possible you know
we don't really know but when it comes
to the MCU Marvel plays it really close
to the vest they keep it grounded in
terms of how it all functions they
engage in magic and mysticism only just
enough to make sure that we know that
it's still fantasy but also keeping it
relatively realistic if they didn't they
were just like hey we're gonna take the
comic-book adaptation of magic and throw
it into the movies Doctor Strange would
be godlie powerful they'd be crazy how
powerful he is in terms of all the stuff
that he could do you'd be like you know
what this problem is solved by a wave of
my hand and an incantation and suddenly
everything's fixed if he uh it'd be
bananas to see it happen but let me know
down in the comments section because I'm
kind of curious who do you guys think
will die do you guys think four will die
do you think Loki will die I am
personally hyped to see Surtur I am so
hyped to see Sir this guy is just stupid
Opie it's crazy how overpowered he is
I'm really excited to see it I think
it's gonna be pretty amazing but anyway
guys I figured I'd throw this little bit
of a speculation video out there let me
know who you think will end up perishing
who will go the way of the dodo and Thor
Ragnarok and yeah I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]